Uh, Raymond Ibrahim joins us from
Budapest. Raymond, I know you're just
back from Oxford. The reason I want to
have you on was one, obviously, this,
uh, you kind of shocked them in Oxford.
But, you're, I believe, if not the best,
one of the top two or three,
uh, best, uh, writers that informs the
West
of this long struggle we've had with,
uh, with Islam. And you've done it
through a series of three books. Uh, in
a time that we're in, uh, another Middle
East war,
uh, with a a radical sect of, uh, of
Islam, the Shiite, uh, you know, the
12th Imam, uh, sect, uh, in, uh, this
kind of radical theology, which we've
been in and out, uh, fighting for 47
years. At the same time, I've been
spending so much time in Texas in the
show, for good reason, about the Islamic
invasion. And I've told people it's much
farther advanced than I thought.
And this deals with the overwhelming
victory we had on the proposition 10 to
ban or prohibit, let me be specific,
prohibit Sharia law in the state of
Texas. Uh, to have your counsel on this
and to put it in historical perspective
is is always important. Uh, do me a
favor and just walk through your
background in in all three of the books.
One of them is out currently. And I want
as many people as possible to buy, plus
the other two. They're they're
fantastic. And they kind they kind of
form a trilogy. Thank you very much,
Steve. Um, yeah, to understand what
we're talking about today, Islam and the
West and all its different iterations,
most recently what's happening with
Iran. I've always believed that there's
been a complete vacuum in your average
American and Westerner in general's, uh,
knowledge of history. And that's why so
much of what we believe and accept and
let get away it happens because we don't
understand the full context of it. And
we just think it's about, oh, you know,
people people are being multicultural
and open-minded and not bigoted towards
Muslims for example,
but if you really look into the history,
which is what I've been doing for about
25 years now actually, including in
those three books which I'll summarize.
If you look at the history, you'll
understand that this battle has been
going on from day one literally. And it
hasn't really changed in its
manifestation, at least not from the
Muslim side. The Muslims are still
preaching Jihad amongst each other.
They're still practicing taqiyya amongst
the infidel
and they're still engaged in all the
various forms of Jihad which they've
articulated. Jihad remember
just means to struggle and sure its
primary expression historically has been
physical military struggle, but it also
has all these different forms which
we're seeing now including the baby
Jihad which is a demographic
overwhelming of the West for example.
The only discontinuity is from the
Western side. So whereas Muslims today
are really you know locked, stock, and
barrel with their their heritage which
comes out in all of these books, it's
the West and especially the Christians
who've completely lost touch with that
long history.
So in these books, we will see for
example in Sword and Scimitar, we look
at this long history that's that's the
first book which comes out in 20 came
out in 2018. I really focus on eight
pivotal battles that changed the world
forever and they were between Christians
and Muslims. And these battles, you
know, the first one or two saw the
conquest of three quarters of what was
once the Christian world which very few
Westerners still understand at this
point. They still think that countries
like Egypt and Syria and Turkey and
North Africa were just always Islamic
somehow. They don't understand that they
were actually more Christian than
Europe. And they were violently annexed
and so that there is a lesson that this
could happen. There's a famous quote I
always talk about from uh Teddy
Roosevelt where he talks about if
Christians did not fight constantly and
he mentions virtually every century
against the Muslims, they would have
been um eliminated completely.
So, uh I think that's uh what people are
forgetting. So, to from my vantage point
or anyone who reads these books, what
you'll see is that the Muslims have been
doing what they're what they've been
doing from day one. Nothing has changed.
What has changed is the Western
response, okay? And that actually the
and the perfect um
you know, seg- that's a good segue for
my second book, Defenders of the West,
The Christian Heroes Who Stood Against
Islam, where I look at another eight men
this time, not battles, but actual men
to see what drove them, Christians,
Europeans, against Islam. And you know,
these these were guys who were really
pious. Uh it's unfortunate because they
get dismissed as oh, and these weren't
true Christians, prob- probably cuz
they're all Catholic because this is the
pre-modern medieval era. Um so, they had
to of course be Catholic and some are
Orthodox. But um you know, they had no
qualms about fighting fire with fire.
They understood that, you know, that
they were not what I'm what I refer to
as doormat Christians. So, they were
quite the opposite. They were immensely
militant, but they were also immensely
pious. And that comes up to the third
book, the most recent one that just came
out in November, The Two Swords of
Christ, which deals with the military
orders. And these were the crème de la
crème of the defenders. These were men
who were essentially monks who were
engaged in such a rigorous form of
essentially monasticism. And at the same
time, they were ferocious warriors.
Okay, so a very strange hybrid for the
Western, especially Christian minds to
comprehend today. But they did it
actually from scripture. So, the title
of the book, Two Swords of Christ, was
one of the verses that they always would
talk about that essentially justified
their rationale. And that's the verse
where in Luke uh Christ Jesus um says,
"Sell your garment, buy a sword." And
they say, "Look Look, Lord, here are two
swords and he says that is enough. That
of course means absolutely nothing today
to the doormat Christian mentality. It's
just, you know, more fuzzy talk. But to
medieval Christians, what it really
meant is there's there's two forms of
warfare that Christians are engaged in.
One of course is against spiritual
forces and one is against secular
material forces, humans, okay? And both
need a sword to be resisted. So that was
the mentality of pre-modern Europe. And
that So now bringing it all forward to
today and coalescing all that has been
jettisoned, Christians, as I argue, have
adopted this sort of doormat
Christianity, as I call it, which means
they believe their faith begins and ends
with doing nothing but being passive,
nice, forgiving, tolerant, and turning
the other cheek. All of which, by the
way, are very easy. Those are a lot
easier to do than to actually stand up
with a sword like their predecessors
did.
Um but that's also why the jihad, after
being stopped and on the retreat,
basically that's what the colonial era
was. This was finally the rise of a
confident West and the demise of Islam.
Now we are it's reversing because the
West has lost confidence, has lost the
ability to resist, has lost its
Christian rationale for just war,
essentially. And Islam is still
continuing to do what it did from day
one.
Uh Raymond, hang on for 1 second. I'll
get into why you were invited Well, how
did Oxford invite you? Well, I'm I'm
currently a visiting fellow at the
Danube Institute in Hungary. And this
particular event was sort of a joint
conference by um
uh it's the the Pusey House of Oxford as
well as the Danube Institute. Um so it
was in that context. And
the event itself Christian revival was
definitely applicable to my themes.
You made a great point. We say this all
the time when when Islam
roared out of
the Saudi Arabian Peninsula
what in the 7th century? For those 100
years
the great cultures, ancient cultures,
and and many of them have had accepted
Christianity. Egypt and Syria being the
two
most significant because the church was
a desert church in those early years.
You had Egypt, Syria, Babylon, which is
modern-day Iraq, Persia
another ancient society had been at war
with the uh Roman Empire forever. And
then Spain.
Um you had uh and then eventually the
Orthodox part of it, Constantinople, all
that.
You had Byzantine culture
which is really the Roman East.
Uh unbelievable uh track record of
overwhelming these societies and taking
over their cultures.
Most people don't know that. They
thought they were Islamic. No, they were
either Zoroastrian as the Persians were
or they had very deep roots in
Christianity. North Africa, I tell
people all the time, Saint Augustine
really I think probably the greatest
intellect we had in the early church
I think was Berber. He was North
African. Uh you had the uh you had the
desert fathers in Egypt and Syria. Um it
was uh the desert church and uh of
course you had all the the saints that
came out of the desert. It really
overwhelmed it. And you really went to
Oxford which was set up Cambridge and
Oxford were set up as great centers of
learning for Christianity when they were
set up.
They've lost their way.
And you really hammered them
on doormat Christianity. Just explain to
our audience
what that means after they heard your
talk. And uh and why did you come up
with that topic uh to go to Oxford and
really to throw down on?
Well, I think what they wanted was for
me to primarily talk about Islam and I
did, but I you know, I I I don't think
it's useful to talk about Islam without
the full context and understanding the
vacuum within Christian civilization
which Islam is filling.
Um and so I decided to address the topic
of a doormat Christianity, by which I
mean uh again this idea, this you know,
that a a real Christian is you know,
just completely passive, uh always turns
the other cheek, never judges, is never
a confrontational, just is a doormat.
And you know, the temptation of that
sort of interpretation is of course
there's verses in the Bible that would
seem to support that sort of thing. But
there's also other verses and anecdotes
from the New Testament, including Jesus'
life, that don't. And I find it
interesting, why does it why do why do
Christians always like to focus on one
without the other? The same Jesus who
said turn the other cheek didn't turn
the other cheek when he was when he was
actually slapped. He questioned and was
confrontational with the person the
soldier who slapped him. And he also he
was he engaged in violence. I think
hurling tables and making
a
a court of whips and whipping both
cattle and humans out of the temple is a
violent expression. So, um I just feel
that Christians need to recapture and
get a balance, a harmony. Okay, what is
a heresy? A heresy is when you really
focus on one aspect of the faith and to
the exclusion of everything else. And I
believe that to a great extent is what
doormat Christianity has become. And
that is why the greatest civilization
born of Christian mores and ethos, the
the West, is completely crumbling
because of this social paralysis that
it's been infected by, which which makes
Christians think that all I have to do
is um you know, just pray and wait and
listen to God and just do nothing. Um
and I'll get better. Well, that's kind
of what's been going on for decades and
uh look where the West is. Look where
Europe is right now. Like I said, Islam
hasn't changed. It's been doing what
it's been doing, swallowing up all if it
if it managed to swallow up the older
as you were mentioning Egypt and Syria
and North Africa and all these nations
that were the heart of the Christian
world. This is where the theology was
coming from. This is where the church
fathers were coming from. And they were
Christian for centuries. And if they
were able to be conquered and swallowed
up, do you think and Europe, we know it
was the final bastion.
It's called the West for a reason. It
was the final western appendage of
Christendom that still didn't get
conquered. And portions of it did for
long periods of time, such as Spain and
the Balkans, um the Mediterranean
islands. So, people have forgotten all
this history and the Muslim impetus has
not changed whatsoever. And but that but
the West and Christians have completely
dropped their guard and they don't feel
like they they can ever engage in
violence or or even be confrontational.
We're at a point where Christians don't
even have to engage in violence. That's
the whole point. Um it but it's going to
get to the point uh where if they don't
do anything, it will be a matter of
survival you know, life or death,
survival of the fittest. But Christians
can't even get to the point where
they're you know, assertive and
confrontational
um about their own particular beliefs
vis-a-vis the other, let's say Islam.
And they always and you know, these
churches in your in your in England that
I visited, they frequently invite Muslim
imams to come and proclaim Quranic
verses, often the ones that are
antithetical to Christianity. And no
Muslim would ever do that. Do you see
this happening in churches in in England
where this interfaith dialogue is what
it's called, is really just kowtowing to
Islam? But Islam doesn't do that.
>> way. It's a one-way dialogue.
>> With you Yeah.
One-way dial- I want to go back in
history though with your writings and
your books. And if we get a chance while
we talk
guys put the covers of the books back
up. Um
it as it blew through Persia and it blew
through Egypt and it blew through North
Africa and it blew through Syria and it
blew through Babylon,
you know, the Tigris and Euphrates, and
then started to blow through the
Orthodox part,
roaring out of Saudi Arabia, it was
stopped really in in places like Vienna
and places like Tours,
uh which people don't realize how deep
into deep into France that was. And then
eventually it was uh reversed in Spain
and Spain won it back. And as soon as
Spain won it back, they started the
exploration of the New World. All of
really modern history is tied to this.
It's antecedents are tied into this
struggle between the Christian West and
Islam. But in reading your books,
whether I'm talking about different
sieges or, you know, in the
Mediterranean islands or in the Balkans
or or uh or up in Europe, it was a
confrontation. If you had not confronted
it
with uh with not just military power,
but the internal fortification of
formation of a religion
that that informed you, informed in your
formation, told you that you must fight
for this, that you cannot surrender that
if you surrender on this, then you're
really not a Christian. You're really
not a believer in Christ. And the the
what it gave the inner energy
of people is throughout your books. And
I think that's the most the two most
important lessons I think that are lost
here is how these cultures and societies
were very developed that they took over
and had deep religious practices.
Particularly in Persia was Persia with
uh with what the the Mithras religion
and then Zoroastrianism.
Uh also up in Syria had turned had
basically started to convert to
Christianity, but they had other
religions too. Same with Egypt. Egypt
has a ancient religious faith, but it
also had many I I think you're of
Egyptian descent. It also had a big
Christian community uh until it was
confronted
by the Christian West in places like
from Vienna to uh
to Tours, right? And then later in Spain
until it was confronted, it was
overwhelming everything. And so the two
lessons is it it's a and they kind of
teach a warrior's philosophy. I think
that's why so many young men are
attracted to Islam. Your thoughts,
Raymond Ibrahim.
Absolutely. And and you nailed it with
that. It is the warrior ethos is so
embedded within Islam and that makes it
has made it originally in its in its
origins and in the now very attractive
to men including Western men who grow up
being told they have to be women
essentially and emasculated or doormat
Christians. They find that appealing but
little do they know that their own
Christian tradition has a very rich
tradition with of of standing up and
fighting back. Okay, the concept of just
war. All those you know, you discussed
all those battles and Vienna and Tours
and it goes on. Even the United States
of America, think about it. This is how
this was a constant thing, you know,
even the United States of America's very
first war as a nation was with Muslims
who were acting and speaking just like
ISIS.
The the Barbary pirates of North Africa
who were kidnapping American sailors and
holding and enslaving them and doing all
sorts of vile things to them. And when
when Jefferson and Adams finally met
with the Barbary ambassador and they
said, "Can't we just be friends? Well,
you know, we did we did nothing to you.
You can have your religion. We'll just
trade." And he just said it according to
our prophet Muhammad, according to the
Quran, "You are the infidel. You are the
enemy. It's our job to lay in wait and
plunder you and enslave you and so
forth." Okay, so even America's very
first experience as a nation put aside
all those other you know, what we were
talking about Vienna and all these major
battles. And you know, you also made
made point about
it's true the entire exploration age as
it's called was also a reflection of
this non-stop constant struggle coming
primarily from Islam. Um Christopher
Columbus and even before him, the
Portuguese Prince Henry, for example,
the reason they were trying to navigate
and go around Africa was always in the
context of the Crusade against Islam,
including to recapture the Holy Land
from Muslims. Uh this would be in the um
1400s, Prince Henry, for example, but
then even later um
uh Columbus
remember, Isabella and Ferdinand were
avowed Crusaders against Islam in Spain
and it's a and they and they were the
final the culmination of the
Reconquista, getting rid of
um Islam after having dealt with it for
7-8 centuries. Okay? And why did they um
get Columbus in their employ? It was in
the context of continuing the Crusade.
Now we've evicted them, now we have to
go back to the holy war. And the reason
they had to sail is because Christians
could not travel by land to the east
because that was where the Muslims, the
Ottomans and the Mamluks in Egypt. And
once you enter there, you're killed or
enslaved immediately. So that's why
that's why they were looking, you know,
for different passages. So I it it's
amazing when you think about that the
very history of the founding, the
existence of the West is so heavily um
shaped by Islam in a negative way, in a
in a violent way. One historian says
Islam was a violent midwife that gave
birth to the West. Henry Pirenne said
the Dark Ages and the and the rise of
feudalism and Charlemagne would have
been impossible without Muhammad. Uh you
know, they're very intertwined but not
in a in a good way. Um and yet that's
all been lost on so many Westerners,
which is why I wrote these books, you
know, to document all this and bring it
back. But it's so lost on Westerners
who've been, you know, believing that oh
all Islam is peace and, you know,
you know, John Esposito, the professor
from Georgetown, he says five Five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed between Muslims and Christians
until an imperial imperial people power
play led to a series of so-called holy
wars which have left a legacy of
enduring mistrust." So, basically, those
centuries we're talking about when
Muslims conquered the old Christian
world and Persia. And we didn't even
talk about further east conquering India
and
Pakistan, of course, where our Indians
who became Muslims after about 80
million of them were killed between 1100
and 1500 and further east and into
sub-Saharan Africa, of course, where now
we're seeing Muslims slaughtering and
engaged in genocide
against Christians. So, all this is
just, you know, yesterday was
Yesterday the day before was combat
combat Islamophobia day, according to
the UN. Okay? That's what we're talking
about, not not this.
No, this is ridiculous. Can we um
in the time we have left
given that we're in a kinetic war
driven by I know you're going to say,
"Oh, it's the nuclear weapon. It's this
and that. It's this and that." It It is
at its essence
it's radical Islam. I'm not saying that
we should have gone at the time we went
or how we went. Let's That's That's a
discussion for another day.
But, you cannot talk about
what's happened in Persia and Iran
without getting to the core of it that
this is the the one of the most radical,
if not the most radical, part
of Islam. And this whole thing with the
Mahdi and the Imam.
And it almost seems like people Oh my
gosh, we got to go back after 9/11. We
have to go back after uh you know, after
the Iraq War after the during the Iraq
War or during the time when President
Trump put the put the travel ban in. We
have to go back and study it. Yes, you
have to. Because
a lot of Westerners like people in
London, the elites in London. Uh people
in Norway, people in Sweden. Uh people
in New York City, some people in Texas.
They believe if you just don't confront
it and you look the other way, it's
going to take care of itself and
everything is going to be fine.
I'm here to disabuse you of that. And I
can point to some of the smartest people
in the world and some of the best
researchers and writers in the world,
they give you a historical record where
that is the exact that does definitely
does not work. In fact, it will lead you
to be conquered. Raymond, in the time we
have left now, given your historical
perspective of their previous invasions,
do we have a fighting chance given the
weak-willed nature of our elites and our
political systems in the Christian West
and particularly the United States of
America to combat this, to stop it and
then to reverse it, sir?
I think you know, the West has
definitely the material forces, the
economy to do what needs to be done. And
but it's as you say, the question is the
will. And
I I I
I don't know because the way I see it I
I I see things from a very kind of
zoomed out long view with his historical
continuities. And if you look even at
the West in just the last 50 years, 60,
70 years, it's a continuous downhill
and there's a you know, it's locked it's
it's connected with its civilizational
degradation, okay? It's it's culture,
it's morals.
You know, this it's funny. I don't know
if I mentioned this to you before, but
the historical Islamic conquest that we
know that we were talking about in the
7th century, you know, historians still
really can't give you an answer how it
happened because Eastern Roman Empire,
the Persian Sassanids were very powerful
and no one really how can some you know,
just a small band of Arabs described
even in Muslim sources as just having
you know, being naked and whatever
weapons they can find, how could they
conquer two empires and then overrun all
these massive lands and you know,
today's historians can't give you a good
answer but they'll come up with
something and I can give you what they
say, but the Christians of the time who
lived there, they were convinced it was
it was God's punishment, that God had
raised this these people up to chastise
them for their sins. And ironically, the
most the most influential writing, it's
known as the Apocalypse by
Pseudo-Methodius, and it it was
published around 690 at the height of
the Arab conquests. It came out in
Syriac, but it continued influencing
Christians even in 1683 of Vienna, it
was being translated and published
within Vienna to explain why Christians
were being attacked by the Turks. And
that one says not only because
Christians had lost their way,
but it was due to sexual immorality. And
it actually talked about men
cross-dressing, women acting like men.
Okay, and it was very very hugely
popular. Now, of course, from a secular
historical point of view, that's
nonsense. That's not why, you know,
Islam prevailed. But when I look at the
current situation today, and I see the
West is so much more powerful than
Byzantium and the Persians were
vis-à-vis Arabia, the West now is much
more powerful vis-à-vis the Islamic
world, and yet look at what's happening.
Muslims are overrunning Europe. They're
having their way. Christian churches are
allowing them to come in and proclaim
the Shahada. While like you said, the
you know, it's not it's not it's a
one-way sort of cultural or religious um
dialogue. So, I'm wondering to what
extent is this the punishment of God?
Because you know, centuries down the
line, you know, when the world
completely changed, posterity will look
back and this will be an even greater
mystery of the original 7th century
conquest. Because all they'll know is
well, we know that Europe and the West
was really really powerful, and we know
that Muslim world wasn't, and that there
were migrants, but somehow or other they
took over, and it's really a mystery.
So, I wonder if it's the same reason
given by Pseudo-Methodius in the
Apocalypse, which is, you know, it
complete immorality, turning away from
God, highlighted and underscored
especially by sexual, gender-confused
type of immorality.
Raymond, where is your institute now?
Where do they get you for your writings?
And where do they go for your
particularly for your books?
Thanks, Steve. Uh my books, you can
probably get the easiest way to get them
is on Amazon. Um Sword and Scimitar,
Defenders of the West, Two Swords of
Christ. There's other books I've written
as well. And um I also have a Substack.
Uh you can follow me there. It's just my
name, Raymond Ibrahim. And I also have a
a YouTube station where you can see my
talk uh that I gave at the um at the
Oxford and also the interesting question
I was asked.
Now, we're play we didn't have chance to
put up the questions. We're going to put
that up on our
live streams. Questions were quite
interesting. Look forward to having you
back and particularly updates as we as
we work through this kinetic conflict in
uh in ancient Persia. Raymond, thank you
so much for joining us. So appreciate
you always. Thank you, Steve.
Bring back
the fire.
the flame.
Bring back the
fire
and the
righteousness.